[Music]
fans around the world are eagerly
awaiting the release of the batman but
the film won't be coming to russian
cinemas why not and how do people feel
about it keep watching to find out the
release of a new batman movie is always
a major film industry event undoubtedly
so when it changes the franchise's
direction in a significant manner or
even better marks the debut of a brand
new actor donning the cape the cowl and
the kevlar armor matt reeves the batman
checks all those boxes and more this
detective noir approach is markedly
different from zack snyder's more
action-oriented batman and robert
battenson's young slightly diy-caped
crusader is a considerable departure
from ben affleck's buff grizzled and
aging dark knight
well
here i am
the movie's casting is also a far cry
from your typical hollywood fair
pattinson paul dano who plays a riddler
and zoe kravitz who plays catwoman may
be no strangers to major motion pictures
but they come with plenty of indie
credibility to go with their requisite
dramatic accomplishments meanwhile
arguably the biggest traditional movie
star in the film colin farrell plays the
penguin under a mountain of makeup and
prosthetics as such there are plenty of
fans who can't wait for the movie's
release both in the us and other
countries it's one of the major
characters of the 20th century and so
many people connect it on such a deep
level and for so many different reasons
in fact with the movie cleared for
release in china the batman might have a
decent chance to become a massive global
super hit a rare feat in this day and
age however there's one market that
won't get to enjoy the movie and it's
jaw-dropping run time because the batman
won't be available in russian movie
theaters let's take a look at the
reasons behind this omission the reason
the batman won't make an appearance in
russian cinemas and the foreseeable
future is a country's invasion of
ukraine according to cnn business this
isn't a logistical issue either the
film's distributor specifically made the
decision to pull the movie the
announcement is one of the most high
profile among the several recent
entertainment industry decisions to take
business away from russia a spokesperson
for the company said in light of the
humanitarian crisis in ukraine warner
media is pausing the release of its
feature film the batman in russia we
will continue to monitor the situation
as it evolves it remains to be seen how
the situation develops but the warner
media spokesperson expressed the
company's wish of how it should wrap up
adding we hope for a swift and peaceful
resolution to this tragedy the latest
developments of the batman and this
russian release or rather lack thereof
have been noted in the people's court of
social media and multiple twitter users
have spoken their minds about the
situation though people appreciate or at
the very least understand the decision
there are different opinions about its
meaningfulness and effectiveness some
people have been quick to show their
support one twitter user wrote the
batman film release is on hold for
russia good moral principle over profits
even in hard times good for warner
brothers another user thought along the
same lines saying i congratulate warner
brothers for pulling out of distributing
in russia what is touted as their
blockbuster of the year the movie the
batman others however were more
skeptical of the move and pointed out
that pausing a movie's release isn't
likely to have a major impact in the
grand scheme of things one doubtful
person sarcastically tweeted that'll
stop them movie companies are really
acting like the batman not releasing in
russia is going to make putin stop
thanks to its impending release date of
the batman and the massive hype
surrounding it warner brothers pulling
the movie from russia is arguably the
hardest immediate blow to the country's
movie theaters however it's far from the
only hit russia has taken from the
entertainment industry as of late in
fact multiple entertainment juggernauts
have made similar decisions on the
streaming side of things netflix
recently refused to add state mandated
content on its platform in russia
according to deadline similarly disney's
release sports in the country means
titles like dr strange and the
multiverse of madness might not see a
russian release sony will do the same
with morbius as well as the other movies
that have planned to release in the
country
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]